je
du bois rouge
plus jeune
il chante l'amour la vie la mort des
amis qui font du rock
après les rues du xviiie arrondissement
de paris les petites bourrettes sont sur
les routes françaises depuis 15 ans on a
commencé dans une formule un peu
acoustique musique de rue à une époque
où à paris c'est un peu compliqué de
faire des concerts amplifiés donc nous
on s'était un peu adapté en faisant une
formule plus acoustique et après vu
qu'on nous proposait de jouer sur des
plus gros sel on a un peu électrifié
notre son
du 26 au 30 octobre il était en
résidence à la verrière quatre jours
pour travailler leur tournée 2010 est
inspiré par leur nouvel album et c'est
encore
oh
bah
tous
c'est là où même si de l'extérieur on
peut avoir l'impression qu'on fout rien
ou pas grand chose en vrai on est tous
en train de cogiter un moment et se
passe un truc et si les trois premiers
jours derrière deux irlandais 4e et 5e
mais à fond on joue à huit heures par
jour et ça finit par donner quelque
chose intéressante c'est là on progresse
aussi vraiment pas ce qu'il faut pas
croire que qu'il n'y a pas de marge de
progrès ou qu'on est donc le fait de
jouer plus fin plus tu joues plus tu es
bon comics et voilà c'est l'occasion de
jouer beaucoup en peu de temps un
nouveau concert à découvrir le 4
novembre scarabée classique et nouvelles
chansons sont au programme du rock des
balades de la valse musette les petites
bourrettes s'adresse à tout le monde
tant qu'ils s'amusent